[Music]
foreign
Valentine's Day in case you didn't
realize in fact if you're a man
listening to this and you just
remembered what day it is don't panic
there's still time to run to the store
on the way home from work pick up a gift
most of the cards and flowers probably
get picked over by now but fortunately
I've always found that the pots and pans
and kitchen utensil aisles the grocery
store is well stocked around Valentine's
Day so grab a box of forks a spatula
maybe a new spaghetti strainer if you
really want to spoil her throw them in a
gift bag you're gonna have a very happy
wife and I'm willing to bet a romantic
evening as well take my word for it of
course not everyone is interested in
Romance and for some even even a brand
new non-stick frying pan wouldn't be
enough to pique their romantic interest
this is the so-called asexual and
aromantic Community Unfortunately they
are the ones that the Washington Post is
thinking about on Valentine's Day
this weekend wapo published a piece
written by a woman named Samantha cherry
or Sherry and titled it was titled quote
how asexual and aromantic people make
Valentine's Day their own now the
article Begins by telling us about a 37
year old person who goes by the name
Obel Pax Odell Pax rather and the post
reports this
Odell Pax identifies as both asexual and
idem romantic which means that she does
not have any desire for sex and she
doesn't make any distinction between
romantic and platonic feelings
so what to do with a holiday that
assumes romantic and sexual attraction
are the norm this year she's doing what
she usually does on February 14th making
time for self-love and self-care for her
that means soaking in a hot bath before
curling up in bed with three with her
three stuffed animals findel Marsha and
Sylvia the last two names are after a
named after trailblazing trans activist
Marcia P Johnson and Sylvia Rivera
yes why not I mean why not tell us the
names of this grown adult stuffed
animals and if that's not enough we're
also treated to a picture of Odell with
the stuffed animals along with this
Caption This is the caption under the
picture it says Odell Pax with her three
dolphin stuffed animals Sylvia findle
and Marsha from left to right
it's a very good thing they specified
from left to right because otherwise we
wouldn't know for sure which stuffed
animal is named Marsha and which one is
Sylvia so now we know and we can sleep
easy tonight
sleep easy anyway with the somewhat
cruel satisfaction we all sometimes
experience after seeing someone else's
utterly pathetic and depressing life and
feeling deeply relieved that it's not
our own life
I try not to Delight in The Misfortune
of others and I don't delight at all in
Odell's misfortunes I don't but I will
admit that when I read this article and
I see that picture I can't help but
think to myself my God I am glad I'm not
that person
anyway here's more from The Washington
Post it says Pax is not alone in
rejecting the notion that relationships
uh acknowledged on February 14th have to
include romance and sex roughly one
percent of lesbian gay and bisexual
Americans are asexual according to a
study from the Williams Institute at the
University of California Los Angeles
although experts such as Jennifer pull
it assistant director of gender
sexuality women's studies at Temple
University in Philadelphia believe the
population is under accounted in its
influence underestimated because of a
lack of awareness sexual intimacy is
often placed on a pedestal to sell
products especially for Valentine's Day
Paul it said but love without romance or
sex is just as valid and fulfilling for
asexual and aromantic people
as more people understand that there
will be more support for people
exploring their relationship wants hopes
and needs in the meantime many people on
the a spectrum also known as a spec or
a-spec an umbrella term for anyone who
identifies as asexual and aromantic are
finding creative ways to define the
holiday on their own terms
now the article does continue providing
along the way more examples and
anecdotes of asexual and aromantic
people celebrating Valentine's Day but I
think we've probably already heard quite
enough
we've heard for example
um this sentence
again roughly one percent of lesbian gay
and bisexual Americans are asexual
now let's think about that bisexual
Americans
are asexual
that is exactly like saying that one
percent of polytheistic people are
atheistic or that one percent of
empathetic people are apathetic you
cannot be something and also the
negation of that thing at the same time
if somebody is sexually attracted to two
Sexes or sexually attracted to the same
sex
that means they do experience sexual
attraction which would seem to preclude
them from claiming the title of asexual
but then again we must remember the
first rule of the LGBT cult which is
that they can make it up all as they go
along and nothing they say has to
comport with anything else they say
and they must never be held to even the
most basic standard of coherence
that's why any attempt to nail down a
definition of what qualifies as asexual
or aromantic
will ultimately wind up as fruitless as
any attempt to get anyone on the left to
give a definition of literally any other
word they use if you ever heard of a
data broker they're the middlemen
collecting and selling all those digital
footprints that you leave online which
includes your browsing history online
searches and location data and they sell
it off to a company that delivers you a
really targeted ad to actually stop
people from monitoring and selling your
online activity you need to do what I do
and use expressvpn think about all the
times you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop
Hotel even a friend's house without
expressvpn every site you visit can be
logged by the Admin of that Network
that's still true even when you're in
incognito mode expressvpn is an app that
encrypts all of your network data and
reroutes it through a network of secure
servers so that your private online
activity stays private expressvpn works
on all your devices it's super easy to
use the app has one button you tap to
connect and your browsing activity is
secure it's as simple as that stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show use my
Link at expressvpn.com Matt walshow to
get three extra months free that's exp
rssvpn.com Matt Walsh show
to prove my point here's the Cambridge
University website attempting to
delineate between these two categories
of asexual and aromantic this is what it
says
asexuality is an orientation defined by
a lack of sexual attraction that means
that an asexual or Ace person
experiences little or no sexual draw
towards others and has little or no
desire to have sexual relationships with
other people however the asexual
Spectrum has many nuanced identities
that fall under the umbrella term
asexual some of the more common ones are
gray sexuality or gray asexuality where
someone experiences sexual attraction
rarely or infrequently another common
identity is demisexuality or Demi
asexuality where someone only
experiences sexual attraction after
forming a close emotional romantic bond
with another person there are many other
identities on the ace Spectrum but what
they all have in common is the lack to
varying extents of sexual attraction
a Romanticism on the other hand is an
orientation characterized by a lack of
romantic attraction while asexuality is
asexual orientation aromanticism is a
romantic orientation and the two don't
necessarily correlate someone may be
asexual but not aromantic or vice versa
or they may be on both spectrums an
aromantic or Aero person experiences
little to no romantic attraction towards
other people and has little or no desire
to form a romantic relationship with
anybody else like asexuality
aromanticism is a spectrum which
includes gray Romanticism or gray
aromanticism where someone occasionally
or rarely experiences romantic
attraction and Demi Romanticism or Demi
aromanticism where someone only
experiences romantic attraction after
forming a strong emotional bond with
another person aromaticism is considered
an umbrella term that encompasses all
the identities that fall on the
aromantic Spectrum
make sense now
now there's a lot going on here actually
uh
let me amend that uh there is nothing
going on here this is a whole lot of
nothing which is trying to sound like
something it's a bunch of narcissistic
fart sniffing mumbo-jumbo dressed up to
sound complex and nuanced when in fact
all the complexities and nuances are
just varying degrees of
self-contradiction
there's actually no meaningful
distinction between sexual attraction
and romantic attraction the two terms
are synonyms if a person told you that
they were romantically attracted to you
but not sexually attracted they will
have given you no useful information
about their feelings towards you
they will however have given you useful
information about the tedious inner
workings of their own inane and
pretentious Minds
as for demi aromanticism or someone who
feels romantic attraction especially
after forming a strong emotional bond
well that is simply called being a
person
I mean it's more common that a woman's
romantic attractions hinges on an
emotional connection
but for men or women this is a rather
normal way for things to work
so here we see again how the LGBT cult
not satisfied to legitimize every
degraded fetish they could find has now
set its sight on fetishizing even what's
normal and healthy
this is a trick they get away with
because as it turns out plenty of
otherwise normal and healthy people want
to be members of The Cult
the best way to rack up Social Capital
is to claim membership in the alphabet
Club
that's because LGBT people in the modern
United States are not only not oppressed
but are in fact the least oppressed
people to have ever walked the face of
the planet
but
what about actual asexual people how
should we understand those people who
really don't experience sexual
attraction and who therefore can validly
claim the label of asexual I think there
are a few things to keep in mind about
this group first of all
I'm extremely skeptical that most of the
people that claim to be asexual are
actually asexual okay because somebody
with a low sex drive is not asexual
someone who doesn't desire romantic
relationships is not asexual
keep in mind the left will always do
everything it can to inflate the
statistics for any of the identity
groups that it invents that's why the
leftist group The Trevor Project has has
a page on its website with information
about asexuals where they stipulate that
asexual people might still quote fall in
love experience arousal and orgasm
masturbate and engage in sexual activity
in other words lots of people they call
asexual
are not at all in any definitional sense
of the term really asexual
most of them are simply just selfish
lonely depressed people with relatively
normal libidos who have chosen
asexuality as their identity group in
order to give some meaning to their
self-centered existence
like most trendy modern identity groups
this one is for the most part just a
cover for narcissism it is a coping
mechanism to cover up a character flaw
which is narcissism
but assuming that there does exist a
collection of people who truly and
through no fault of their own have no
sexual attraction no desire to uh for no
desire for sex at all no capacity for
sexual arousal Etc then we could say two
things about this group number one it's
almost certainly very small it's not
gonna be anywhere near one percent or
even half of one percent
number two it's not an identity least of
all a sexual identity if you truly lack
the ability to experience sexual
attraction
then something has likely gone awry
physiologically you have an issue that
you might try to fix rather than making
it into your whole personality
now you shouldn't be ashamed it's not
your fault but you also shouldn't make
your inability to experience sexual
attraction into the centerpiece of your
identity as a human being
neither does it make sense to be proud
of this inability I mean the only thing
more bizarre than marching around and
claiming to be proud of your sexual
attraction is marching around and
claiming to be proud of your lack of
sexual attraction
and that's why today on Valentine's Day
I will not cancel all asexuals they have
enough to deal with especially on a day
like today instead I'm specifically
canceling these flag waving asexuals
like those profiled by The Washington
Post especially the ones who have
stuffed animals that they name
they are all today canceled and that'll
do it for this portion of the show if
you want to become a member so you can
watch the members blog become a member
and use code wall to check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you over the members block if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]